welcome to the across the spoiler vers
podcast ooh we're getting creepy cuz
it's Halloween everything's getting dark
I'm joined from across the pond by Greg
Alba I feel like I'm the character in a
horror movie who I'm talking to you on
Skype I'm just about to tell you
something really important about the
villain and then the screen starts
static in like oh someone's coming I'm
dead but yeah so if you can like the
video guys that' be a massive help uh as
always we are on Spotify Amazon music
podcasts all around the globe and yeah
Greg how's it going good to see you
again it feels like even though it's
only a week every time I think we both
get up to so much during that week that
by the time we see each other again it's
like it's been five months since I last
seen you how's life it's it's busy man
do I hear a little are you doing scary
voice or is there a tingle in your
throat right now oh I've had a cold like
really badly um and it was absolute so
as many of you know we we get Loki
episodes early the first four anyway um
so I've been preparing that I've got had
my script written and recording it over
the weekend was an absolute nightmare
because I kept losing my voice so I
would record like a five minute chunk
lose it and then have to spend the next
four hours getting my voice up to
scratch oh and it's been a nightmare if
I can give you guys any advice out there
don't ever have twins yeah because the
amount of diseases they bring in I I
feel like a broken record but every
couple of months I'm literally well not
even every couple of months it's like
every couple of weeks I'm having to
apologize for having a cold and the
listeners having to Bear the brunt of it
because I I can't imagine it sounds nice
but I've got I've been told it gets
better after the first year it gets a
bit better it actually sounds
appropriately soothing it's got a little
bit of a baritone rasp to it I enjoy it
I think it's nice on the ears Paul I've
be getting them to cough in my face I'm
like go on make the voice sound better
coughing my face I want the sexy rasp go
coughing
so yeah last week we talked about how
the um writer strike had come to an end
we kind of went through all the deals
that had been marked out and our first
story this week is that the SAG after a
strike that they're going to negotiate
this week um so negotiations according
to deadline they started on Friday and
have started up again today and talks
are apparently proceeding calmly Greg
how are you feeling I'm very optimistic
about this I don't think it'll take as
long as last time I think your voice is
doing magical wonders I wasn't calm
until you said that you're feeling
calmly about it and now I feel a lot
more at ease about the preceding sag
negotiations your voice is doing just
melts melts my spirit way uh yeah I
think it's a good thing I think after
the writer strike there's some hope
granted there's a lot of differences
between what the writers are asking for
and what the actors are asking for but
there's a lot of similarities but I
think the similar ities do Aid in making
the negotiation process probably go
faster for these things and it also
shows that the studios are serious and
it also shows that the studios are
willing to to play ball uh a little bit
at least and I guess the question is is
how much will they concede you know
because there was quite a bit of
capitulation I would say when it came to
the rider strike they got a little bit
more than a lot of us expected them to
and well the SAG people be able to get
as much as they want but we'll see man
we'll see it'll be a good time we've
really got like an NPR thing going on
today I I'm really enjoying it I'm I'm
less about the visual of the camera and
more about the audio now it's really
enjoyable I'm gonna just bring this a
lot closer in my mouth today
wga so yeah um obviously the wga they
secured a deal and I feel that I don't
feel like the studio can come in and be
like well I know we agree to all that
stuff but we're not agreeing to any of
your things I I feel like the the sort
of Standards being set for where
Hollywood are going to be at right now
and what they kind of know they have to
bring to the table they can't just come
in and be like well we're not doing any
of that because they've already agreed
to stuff with the writers so I'm hoping
that they've just gone in and being like
oh you know what we're going to have to
give them what they want it's a
three-year contract at the end of the
day you know it's not locking them in
for it's it's probably as long as most
mobile phone contracts are these days so
I'm hoping that they just go in get it
sorted and we can get back to business
is it's a bit weird that they delayed
Dune to cuz I was like I I was fully
expecting the strikes to be over and I'm
if they are over I think that'll be a
massive mistake now the big topic we'll
be talking about later on in the podcast
is some of the dumbest decisions ever
made in Hollywood so we're giving you a
bit of a teaser there we'll see if June
2 ranks up there but I think moving it
to March um from November when I mean it
had all those IMAX
screens exclusive very little
competition whereas March next year it's
pretty hectic it's pretty hectic I think
there's a different Big T pole movie
every other week um so we we'll see how
it goes but um there's been lots of
striking developments across the
industry as well as VFX workers at
Disney have voted unanimously to
unionize so lots of things could be
happening there I mean imagine if we get
out of this these two strikes and then
the VFX artists go on strike as well be
it's a bad in Hollywood those delays and
I think the VFX artists um especially at
Disney because they've gotten a lot of
criticism however you know they've got a
lot of criticism but a lot has been
pulled out from behind the wall to show
us that it's because there's a lot of
like crack in the whip a lot of last
minute changes a lot of burnout a lot of
overworked hours there's a lot of
variables that work against VFX workers
and and I think when you look at the
effects of something like um
I guess what I'm trying to say is that
there was a time where people were
talking about the VFX work in Disney and
then really complaining about it and
then they found out why it it can be not
looking the greatest right but then when
you see something like Ahsoka where it
looks really great and or for the most
part or and then even looking at Loki
that're like oh wow so much of this
looks so great then then I think you get
even more people behind the VFX workers
going this is why you should really pay
them properly this is why you should
take care of them because look what
happens when they're allowed to do good
work so I'm I'm full support of them man
100% agree I mean I often it's such a
hard job doing bfx work and that often
the designs get scrapped and thrown away
they'll work on whole sequences
everything will get nailed down and then
the director or the studio will be like
actually can you change this bit and
they'll have to rework the entire thing
and there's lots of crunch time involved
in it it's a very very very
talented position and I often see things
where people post screenshots or clips
from movies from 10 years ago and say
how come the VFX look so much better
then than they do now and it's not
because the artists are less talented
it's because the way the studio is
running things now and overworking them
and not giving them enough time to do
things and when you look at movies today
compared to how they were even 10 years
ago it's they're almost like animated
movies at this point for ex if you ever
see a behind the SC if you if you watch
the behind the scenes stuff of say Iron
Man or The Avengers where everyone says
oh the VFX are still hold up in this
stuff a lot of it's on set and they
they're using real backgrounds real sets
and so on so that's not having to be
animated whereas if you look at films
now behind the scenes it's all pretty
much green screen and blue screen in the
background so all that's yeah all that's
got to get animated all that's got to
get put together and then on top of that
you have to provide the the figures and
stuff so yeah they're pretty much making
animated movies at this point that just
have actors moving around the spaces and
stuff and it's so much more work and
yeah just the way things are short the
Creator is a great example of how to do
VFX properly uh which is they nailed
down the Final Cut of the film before
they ever sent it off to have bfx work
on it um and I feel that's the way you
know you should kind of be looking at
doing stuff obviously it's not you you
you are going to have change like I'll
I'll work on a video and and see
something and be like Oh wish I could
change that and I can imagine a film
where you been working on it for years
and years you'll see something we go
well can't we do this instead um but
yeah it's it's a it's a strange time and
we've also seen some repercussions from
the the writer strike as the writers of
Drew Barrymore's show they've declined
to return to the series after she
attempted to scab apparently and
continue the show without them this is
what we were talking about man it was
like this decision was terrible because
you weren't thinking about the long-term
repercussions of what could happen with
this hey it's like yeah you want to make
sure your celebrity Talent is willing to
agree on this show first and foremost
and you don't want to have the scab
angle behind that but then B it's like
well dude you also got to think about
when the writer strike is done are your
writers going to want to return after
this you know whether or not you were in
agreeance with Drew Barry more willing
to return or not um that doesn't really
matter it was always about the Optics
and it was also about the way the writer
her writers were feeling like this is
this is terrible for her this is this is
really bad and sure they might they'll
be able to find some other writers I I
believe they will be but I think a lot
of people would not feel like they would
want to publicize that they're part of
the drewberry Moore Show after something
like this you know I think this is
really yeah this is really troubling
turbulent times at The Drew Barrymore
show I'm quite surprised she wasn't part
of or isn't part of sag to be honest I
would have thought I mean she's
obviously she not part of well no but
I'm like why I'm guessing she is so I'm
obviously they're on strike so she must
know people involved in the strike and
that must be affecting her as well I
know I know a talk show how different
but I'm guessing she's still part of sag
um so yeah it's a bit strange that she
kind of took that position in the first
place espe I I would thought her being
an actor would have been like oh we
stand with the writers and the actors
but guess not but um yeah the the
strikes have obviously you know had
their knock on effect which takes us
into our next topic we're flying through
them today Greg it's Marvel delays yeah
you're calm and collected you're smooth
I I love the way you were handling the
transitions there's a lot of which takes
us into the next topic there's a lot of
pre-planning here I think this is really
well structured podast today too too
struct like I've been in bed all week no
I haven't the worst thing is when you're
a YouTuber gang I know we we've got
we're very lucky to be in this position
but talking about movies all day but the
bad thing is when you're
ill you you just got to work through it
mate you've just got to work through it
what you mean you also have to work
through it because you have a proper job
listening right now I'm sorry guys you
know what I'm saying um no one's more
self-absorbed than YouTubers all right
no no one feels they have the hardest
time in the world than you it's because
we're we subjugate ourselves to people's
opinions about us so I think we just
wait let it wa on us but let's talk
about these Marvel delays man no
honestly Greg I remember I was at a
wedding once and I was sat talking to
this woman and she was like oh what do
you do and I was like oh I'm a YouTuber
she's like oh how's that and I was like
oh you know blah blah blah not all this
cracked up to be it's lots of Hard Times
sitting around making videos talking
about Marvel movies and pointing out
Easter eggs it's so difficult I was like
and what do you do and she was like oh I
worked as a Frontline nurse during the
pandemic and I was and I just my heart
sank and I was like oh you know what I'm
very lucky um there's people actually
doing really hard work out there and
hopefully enjoying it with a lovely
podcast that they can listen to because
I know some of you guys you guys are
getting paid right now to listen to
podcast so uh y you checky little monkey
you we're hoping we're making the time
fly we are a necessity part of you
getting away from your hard life for
just one and solid hour as you want to
hear about what's going on with Marvel
delay yeah I'm bringing us back what did
the cosmic circus say Paul yeah so
according so the cosmic circus put out a
report saying according to the US
copyright office which was actually this
report was found with Scarlet Witch
update um the Agatha show is expected to
release September 29th
2024 in addition they also found out
Daredevils listed as expected to release
January
2025 and iron Hearts expected to release
September 3rd
2025 I can't wait to commit my birthday
to iron my birthday yay oh no way yeah
it's going to be a good birthday well if
it makes you feel better that date's not
locked in and I'm guessing it's going to
get delayed um but I actually I went
back to the original slate that they
posted in July 2022 last year so summer
2023 was supposed to be Echo lowkey
season 2 was supposed to be summer
2023 the Marvels that was meant to be
July 28th 2023 November 3rd Greg was
going to be
blade fall 20123 was going to be Iron
Hort then winter 2023 was Agatha spring
2024 was Daredevil and then we go into
Captain America and the Thunderbolts so
it's insane when you think about how
much this stuff's been delayed and I
looked it up and iron har actually
wrapped production in November
2022 so by the time it releases in
September
2025 it's going to be two years since
they finished filming it wow which is
absolutely insane like you think about
how tight Marvel used to be in all every
they had everything in place and worked
out and I think it's just insane that
it's been delayed that much and now when
I brought this up people are saying like
because it's woke and it's crap and
stuff and I I don't know if that's the
case mate you've not seen it um but it's
it's just insane how much mismanagement
there almost is in Hollywood at the
moment and for it to finish production
and be two years behind I mean I know
they said they were delaying Marvel
project Jacks but wow that is crazy I I
think they've just hit a point where
they've thought we really need to
reassess what we're doing because not
everything's hitting it out the park and
I mean when was the last billion dollar
MCU film and that used to be a given
obviously the pandemics affected it but
even the even the conversation
surrounding Loki season 2 seems like the
show is not as big as a lot of people
expected it to be I I see it on the
especially in the breakdown Community I
even thought our reaction for it would
be significantly bigger considering the
level of hype and how well-received Loki
season 1 was as well and it does make
you kind of wonder about hey is it
actually Paul started changing something
on the Google Doc while I was talking
and I was like what is he doing and now
I'm like oh I didn't realize Paul could
change this Google doc in real time all
the way in the UK before my
sponsored by Google docks so um uh yeah
no but it's it is making me wonder if
like spreading it out is probably part
of their strategy actually I don't
really know how this ties into what I
was saying with Loki season 2 um but I
think show showcasing a little bit of
damage brand could be applicable with
the how Loki season 2 is not as big as a
lot of us thought it would be uh in
terms of numbers despite how well
received it is right now I mean it's
week one
it is week one still it's Loki season 2
though you know um I really thought it
would I think a lot of us thought it
would be like She-Hulk episode one got
bigger numbers than than Loki season 2
did um the the the the thing with Disney
plus that a lot of people are often
talking about like this week they have I
think they have like Goosebumps that is
simultaneously debuting with Hulu
there's not much hype around that they
try to get hype around other things but
the only things that really Get Hype are
their Star Wars and Marvel properties
and I think when you spread them out
like this for the stuff that's going to
be Disney plus exclusive it does kind of
force you to stay subscribed if you do
really care to be you know a part of the
journey when it comes to the Marvel and
Star Wars exclusive content that goes on
Disney plus uh so I think this could be
in conjunction with part of that
strategy that's just a theory so yeah I
mean I feel like it's sound the because
that's a that's a really big that's a
really massive delay you know yeah I
feel with in the case of iron har I feel
like it's a mistake and that is because
obviously you know Iron har was
introduced during wakanda forever wak
forever yeah yeah and I feel like it's
just a bit too much of a delay almost to
to stay interested in that character or
to at least you know strike W iron's
heart and and I feel that's the same
with Agatha as well Daredevil I think
there's always sort of that hype around
him so they can kind of get away with it
but Agatha and einhart especially I
think you needed maybe bring it in
closer and yeah just drop it more closer
to One Division and wakanda forever to
really in you know get get the hype
Because by the time like Agatha let's be
honest was pretty much green lit off the
fact that Agatha all along song did
really well on Spotify hell yeah that
was like two years ago now and it's
going to be about three years I don't
know if song's got enough staying power
for people to be like okay I know we
didn't care about Loki but we're coming
back for that so very very strange
tactic I think obviously that they've
seen their numbers dwindle and they
realized that dropping too much content
kind of robs people of anticipation
because you're getting it all the time
and you just sort of need a gap in
between stuff to really build up hype or
something need the tension
build sexual build
yeah I don't think it's indicative of
the quality of these shows per se I just
think it's more sort of I mean we we do
constantly complain as well that you
know Disney need to listen to fans and
and whatever and though I don't feel
Star Wars fully does that I feel Marvel
at least pays attention to fans and is
like okay we're we're getting enough
feedback from this to kind of realize
where we've gone wrong yeah and Blades
also been delayed apparently they're
they're writing a new script for it I
mean that movie's been in development
hell almost like the amount of things
I've heard about it behind the scenes of
it being you know starring danne Whitman
and then not in the next draft and then
being about his daughter and then not in
the next draft and yeah it just kind of
sounds all over the place a bit with
that but I'm happy to wait if stuff's
good you bring up stuff so much that I
forget like so much has happened in the
last few years in Marvel I honestly
forget about some even Agatha all along
I haven't thought about that since W
Vision was on air you know I'm like oh
yeah that was that was the talk when
that when that song was out that
everyone was talking I mean w division
in general was the talk and then you're
mentioning blade oh yeah crap there was
this whole thing where they announced
Marshall Ali and it was this huge deal
and then he was teased at the end of a
etals it was like actually in the post
credit scene it's just kind of nuts when
you think about how much is like oh yeah
this happened this happened and you
forget about it and I do wonder if that
has factored into the Loki season 2
effect because we all really thought
that Loki season 1 had the the massive
consequential uh Catalyst into what will
be the Multiverse Saga right like going
into doctor strange and all that and oh
we're going to see how Loki season 2's
cataclysmic events will ultimately
Ripple through the preceding Marvel
Cinematic Universe and we didn't really
see that effect so I'm kind of wondering
if people are really at that point where
they feel like you know maybe Loki
season 2 is maybe inconsequential or not
as necessary to really experience it and
I feel like that's the case in general
with all these Disney Plus shows not all
of them that there are some that are
consequential but I think people have
kind of got wise to them not fully
mattering or if they do then it's like
yeah it's down the line and they're not
in a rush to watch it the way I would
compare it to is you know marvel or or
comic book company obviously they have
hundreds of titles where it's Side
characters that get their own runs and
you know what I'm saying Greg you don't
just have yeah you don't just have your
Avengers comic Iron Man comic and
Captain America comic whereas with the
movies you would have those ones and I
think they've kind of tried to go often
into the comic model where it's almost
like give every hero a show and everyone
who seems interested in something will
give them a series or include them in
other stuff and I'm sure you know with
Comics yourself you don't re like I love
reading comics but I don't pick up every
single issue about every single other
character um to stay on top of stuff and
I tend to just read the main massive
arcs and I kind of feel that's going to
be the same with the general audience
too where they're going to come in for
the massive movies you know your
Avengers and I'm really surprised they
haven't done an Avengers movie since
endgame that I I I feel that that's a
missed opportunity there I think that
would have got a lot of people invested
and rather than having these dwindling
numbers would have been like oh well we
need to get caught up to this stuff
because Avengers movies coming but all
that to the side I feel the general
audience is going to pay attention to
the big names but not necessarily the
smaller ones and that might fracture
down to some shows being missed again we
are in episode one of Loki season 2 I I
personally believe it will pick up I
think the you know from what I've read
on the reviews and stuff people have
said that there's good stuff coming and
I don't want to skip ahead and spoil it
for myself but I do feel that the
audience will get there and that is
something that we see with a lot of
Disney Plus shows as well you know the
first week it's okay and then again it's
good with the mouth and then the numbers
just build and build and build for
example Ahsoka we I don't think we've
had the numbers for episode four or five
yet with Anakin in but I can imagine
those episodes were quite big because I
remember them trending and obviously
there stuff that happened in it and I
can see a similar sort of thing
happening with Loki as well I hope so I
hope so I hear a puppy I hear a puppy in
the background I love a good puppy um
the Amazon stuff for me oh there you go
um I think yeah I mean to kind of like
wrap it up on this point uh I heard your
best friend Ryan Ary and your worst
enemy Ryan Ary he said something that
was uh I think what he it was along the
lines of Ahsoka he feels like could have
been wrapped up in an opening crawl that
what happened in that uh show that you
don't really need to watch it that you
can kind of just explain the events in
an opening crawl
and that is when like it makes me think
of what you're saying with comic books
like I A lot of times I don't read this
I won't read the cun they usually can
just sort of explain what happened
really quick in a text and that's kind
of the problem that happens with a lot
of the Marvel properties as well is
unless you really want to catch like
specific Easter eggs and whatnot like
the Marvels is coming out but I'm really
under the impression that I actually
don't need to watch even though I have
seen them I don't feel like I actually
need to have see Miss Marvel or Wanda
Vision because they could probably
quickly explain to me what I need to
know and they do a good job at that so
it actually it it h because that's part
of the weird thing with Marvel and
thinking about the Marvels which is
putting together three different
specific properties W division Miss
Marvel and Captain
Marvel that you you want to make sure
that if they didn't see the shows they
can that people can still enjoy the
movie and keep up with the movie at the
same time because they structure their
movies like that it can make people go
well I don't need to watch the shows I
don't need to watch W Division I don't
need to watch Miss Marvel and that kind
of attitude just kind of bleeds over
into a lot of Marvel Now of do I really
need to watch it where before everything
felt like it needed to be watched and I
think that's kind of the problem when
they just because at first the idea of
doing television shows sounded like the
greatest Prospect for Marvel it's it
sounded like awesome like oh we finally
get some real exploration and at first
it was amazing you know W division Loki
I even really like Falcon a winter
soldier enjoy mood Knight there's a lot
of great things that have come from the
Disney plus side of Television but the
commitment level that you ask for from
audiences on that
scale is it's it's a much that's much
tall big that's a much bigger order to
ask you know and the fact that you can
sort of explain away a lot of things
that happen if when you're doing
crossovers with just essentially the
idea of an opening crawl but just in a
few sentences on
screen but that's because you couldn't
really do that with a sooko with a A lot
of people were still kind of lost on the
characters of like the significance of
like Ezra Bridger and whatnot they that
a lot of that information would come
late but Marvel they are in this weird
hole right now where a lot of their
stuff doesn't feel as necessary when
that was the probably their main driving
force was how it felt like necessary
viewing and now the brand is more
damaged than ever because a lot of their
stuff does not necessitate viewing I I
feel it does because I like to get all
the details and whatever and I like the
journey the experience but for most
audiences it it show it shows in the
numbers the numbers show that yeah I
mean I I would watch it either way I
love this stuff um yeah but yeah like
with Ahsoka and Rebels that was another
example where it was kind of like I feel
like not not that many people went back
and watched through Rebels to get caught
up with a SOA and there were some parts
here and there obviously it' enhanced
your enjoyment if you knew that stuff
but I feel that's the same with the the
films and they have to kind of be aware
that people aren't going to have watched
the show so they have to make them
newcomer friendly as well it's a really
weird place to be in um but as a fan you
know I I still like this stuff I'm still
invested in I know I get called a hater
all the time and stuff but it it is kind
of sad when you see something you love
that was so beloved by so many people
not getting the the love or admiration
that it used to and I I kind of feel
like on some things it's lost its way
which is why I was so excited for Loki
and yeah the numbers have kind of been
all over the place on it we will see
what they are officially but just you
honestly the whole week was just YouTube
as messaging me going are your Lo lowkey
views doing well is it doing well in the
video and I was say it's it's doing not
it's fine it's okay it's worse than
She-Hulk and he was like yeah yeah it's
worse than She-Hulk for me and I was
like okay I'm fine though don't wor are
you okay he was like yeah I'm okay I'm
okay it's like it's going to be long six
weeks mate yeah
know not afford to buy my my children
coffee for Christmas or something I
don't know why I don't know why I
brought up coffee for Christmas but you
know what I mean but we'll be elderly
YouTubers that you're you're friends
with me yeah me by the looks of it these
days I'm like 35 years old jeez Ryan
AR's about 50 years old mate don't
tell yeah so uh well that's why I put it
all on the dog yeah so speaking of
Marvel I thought we'd do a quick little
discussion about Loki episode 2 I I
enjoyed it have you seen it I uh yeah I
didn't I I I really enjoyed it too I
didn't love it uh to the degree of the
first
episode um yeah there's a bit of there a
bit of it was you you actually messaged
me you're like hey is something right
about this episode and I didn't know
what you were talking about and I feel
like it's it's is it a spoiler to to
mention what you were ask because
because I as I felt it was it's the way
it begins the yeah the the first like
five seconds it was jarring to me too I
I had to question it of like wait a
minute what what's happening here and
and um because of that it does feel like
they there's some stuff that feels like
they Rush past it it's kind of weird
like there's there's a lot of great
scene work still I think there's some
amazing scene work here the acting it's
topnotch directing cinematography still
really top-notch um but there is some
weird
pacing things and and some stuff that
probably didn't need to be as gestated
on for as long and then other parts feel
rushed uh it's not as crisp or solid I
still like it I'm still invested um but
yeah it's like the first one was just so
like exciting and you know visually
impressive and like whoa weird and this
one really uh it it it speeds up but
then it really pushes the brakes it's
kind of it's kind it's weird to talk
about without going into specifics um
but it's not as strong I would say it's
the mirror image of episode two from
season one and by that I mean it's about
some characters meeting up with other
characters we know that look we know
they're going to meet up McDonald's
spoiled the entire scene if you know
that then you know what I'm talking
about um and it's kind of going through
the motions to get to that point most
it's it's one of those episodes where
it's like well we know these characters
have to meet about the end how are we
going to present that in a way that
feels natural and fluid and it's just
kind of going through that now that can
be a problem but where I think it excels
at is in the execution of it and there's
some really good moments that they have
with certain characters especially Loki
throughout Loki we we've seen him kind
of you know doing maybe anti-hero stuff
but he's never out and out being a
full-on villain that he once was and in
this episode he does some villainous
stuff where it's like oh I can see that
and we really get to see Tom hedleston
kind of flexes his villain stuff it ends
in a quite a climactic way well not
climactic but there's consequences to it
and it's sort of a reverse of season 1
episode two and when you see the episode
that might make sense I'll explain it to
you I didn't even think about that I
didn't even think that did not even
think about that but you're yeah you're
100% right um I will say too uh Owen
Wilson's work in this episode really
strong stuff I love what there's another
character in there I don't want to yeah
it's so hard not to spoil stuff there's
another character there who I was like
oh I didn't realize this character would
be so prominent um but Owen Wilson and
him have some like some of the most
memorable stuff out of Loki for me I I
really love their scene work together
yeah again like it's like solid scene
work like the scene the acting is
impeccable man it's really really just
that's that's the interesting thing is
it becomes a little bit more like um
it's something that you kind of want it
it it it becomes less like Big World
building and a little and and it does
zero in more on the characters uh and
sometimes that does mess with a little
bit of plotting uh but I I still think
it's better than a lot of other things
we've been getting like by a lot you
know yeah that's that's what I'm trying
to say basically you know it's if you
wrote down what happened in the episode
and sent it to someone they' be like
didn't really sound that good but it's
the way they executed and Carri it out
it's it's you know it's it's not I
personally didn't enjoy as much as the
first episode but I feel it was
definitely executed well and as far as
episode two in the SE like in across
pretty much every single TV show of all
time episode 2 is always kind of the
step down because they get a big budget
for the show they put most of it into
the pilot and then the second episodes
when they kind of have to tone back and
maybe set things up for what's going to
be coming in the episodes down the line
like episode one of a a season I always
find is kind of almost self-contained
like it has a middle beginning well
beginning middle and end um or middle
beginning and end with low middle
beginning and end but yeah yeah so it's
it's
um episode ones are normally outstanding
they put everything they can into it
because they want the show to get a big
audience behind it talk about how good
it is and then episode two is normally
sort of a step down and then it's like
episode four where stuff really kicks
off uh I yeah I feel it was your classic
sort of episode two thing where it's a
slight step back you're getting more
centralized character
performances uh but the work there is
really good it's just kind of yeah I'd
say episode one was like a five out of
five and there like a four out of five
that makes sense I think that that part
that brings it down to a four out of
five is just a little more strongly felt
because episode one was so good you know
what I mean like if episode one wasn't
as great as it was I don't think there
would
be because it's still it's the weird
part like it's still no it's still a
really good episode it's just that that
part that is a step down you feel it a
little stronger only because you're
coming off of how G so I think actually
like you know putting that out there
would help because now that we put that
out there people might low their
expectations and they go and like I
don't know what you're talking about
that was better than episode one because
we lower you know how it go because we
lowered the expectations still a really
good show though definitely speaking of
lowering
expectations The Exorcist believer well
there's been loads of stuff coming out
about it this week um so it turns out
that Universal actually spent $400
million to acquire the rights to the
release of it so they could make a new
Trilogy it's come out it's h it's not
done well it's done pretty badly the
they they were expecting a 28 million
debut and yeah it's it's it's not going
well I didn't go see it Greg I was on
the edge of it I was like do I go do I
not go and then they posted a clip
online of a line from it and I was just
like oh I'm gonna give it a Miss um so
well it all it got terrible reviews and
a terrible audience score so there's
going to be no on this movie really bad
and and Scott menson actually brought up
a really good point talking about the
whole $400 million for the rights thing
obviously Universal you know they've
tried to capture lightning in a bottle
again like they did with Halloween that
first Halloween recel where they got
David Gordon and green in they got
Legacy characters from the franchise and
they just hit the ground running with it
so Menon was saying that Exorcist it's
not Halloween in terms of IP for example
he brought up having Ellen Burston come
back it's not the same as bringing back
Jam Lee Curtis fighting Michael Myers
again completely agree and yeah it's I
mean the excist just I I one of the
greatest movies of all time I think that
first film it's not just one of the best
horrors of all time it's one of the best
movies of all time but the sequels and
what followed it they don't have the
Legacy that the Halloween sequels do I
mean how many times have they rebooted
that Halloween Universe there's been
like so many different timelines remakes
reels that ignore all the sequels and
stuff like that Lor str's a Legacy
character you know whereas alen buron
was I wouldn't call it like a legacy
like it's a major character but it's not
it's just not the same level where she
carried through the franchise yeah and I
think they really tried to just think
how do we do that again and we buy The
Exorcist for 400 million from Morgan
Creek who must be laughing about it
rolling rolling in pools of money um we
get the we get David Gordon green back
we get a Legacy character back we make
it a direct sequel to the first film Ro
kind of ignore the other sequels and
yeah it just didn't work out for them um
I think you know something that we talk
about quite a lot on this show is horror
movies and how cheap they are to make
and if you're paying 400 million out the
gate I don't think you're ever going to
make that back unless it's like you know
a massive massive hit because that was
just for the right that was just to get
the yeah you know like damn that's a lot
so that's yeah that's before they've
ever shot anything before they've ever
sat down and cast anyone or wrote a line
of dialogue it's crazy it's absolutely
crazy and I think they just needed to
really analyze the situation and see
what was going on like I mean the
Exorcist was so much of a cultural
movement at the time as well it was very
much a sort of test your faith film
where a lot of people like we've talked
about this in the case of sound of
freedom and stuff where when the church
backs a
film it gets so much more money for
example something like Passion of the
Christ or something lots of people come
out to see it and this was obviously set
in the 70s for all the Catholic Church
scandals and stuff like that and
religion was really really a bankable
thing and going to see a movie where
it's about the devil possessing a girl
you know it's almost testing your faith
and I feel The Exorcist will have
renewed a lot of people's Faith as well
so it was very much a cultural thing
sort of can you survive the movie about
the devil you hear about all the curses
and stuff back then mind-blowing crazy
thing insane these days there's hundreds
of possession movies and yeah it's it
paying that much money for that we had
the pop excist this year
exactly yeah I mean it's so overdone
obviously the the The Exorcist was such
a big film I think it got 10 Oscar
nominations or something and one of
those was best picture and people have
just been trying to redo that and live
up to that again and it's it's not gonna
happen and I think getting David Gordon
green on board was just stupid anyway
the second I heard that yeah I was like
dude you don't want to get a guy who's
like over this it's like that's I
think that's I think John watt's leaving
fantastic 4 was so smart of him to do
that you know like I can't imagine going
from Spider-Man to it's like David Yates
did all the freaking Harry Potter movies
he's like all right I guess I'll do
fantastic Beast now you know like you're
you're just gonna and while I actually
like that first movie you're just gonna
lose that magic touch you your your your
passion gets diluted over time you know
like oh God I gotta start this all over
again I gotta try if it he had to have
he should have probably done something
more in between before just making the
jump to be yeah a producer director
essentially like all right I'll get this
going you know yeah and just hearing all
the stuff this weekend it put me off
wanting to see it there's obviously
audience members that didn't go to see
either because the the movies not made
that much but it kind of takes us into
our main topic of the show which you
know obviously The Exorcist the rights
to it cost $400 million before they made
anything so put out a tweet asking what
are the dumbest decisions in Hollywood
that there's ever been in Hollywood what
dumb decisions have have Hollywood
people made made so we're going to avoid
controversial subjects like John Landis
causing the death of the actor from The
Twilight Zone and those two kids on that
set interestingly me and Philip Molina
we've we've actually done a podcast
breaking down in that but it's not out
because it's taken forever to edit but
it's a very messed up story and yeah
it's horrendous story and what happened
on that but we're not going to say stuff
like that because it's obvious it's a
given so what the stuff's going to be
like is like sewing up Deadpool's mouth
in X-Men Wolverine Origins you know what
I mean just stupid stuff like that keep
it light-hearted guys I know there been
a bad week in the world we don't want to
delve into nasty nasty nasty things um
but I put out a tweet saying what are
the dumbest dumbest things in dumbest
decisions in Hollywood and for me right
one of the most dumbest ones was when
John Carpenter Kurt Russell and Keith
David they were all on board for a thing
Sequel and then Universal instead of
going with a prequel they decided to get
someone who never directed A Hollywood
movie before and then they replaced all
the Practical effects with
CGI now that was insane to me I had no
idea about that until I saw your
Tweet yeah that is nuts to me
that is absolutely absur because you
know and John Carpenter wanted to come
back to to write and to direct that one
at
least yeah no he he was going to work on
the script they were going to get the
team back said after that first film get
everyone back everyone's on board and
then Universal's like nah we're going to
go with the guys who did the Dawn of the
Dead remake because that's
crazy I do wonder if it would have been
good though because John Carpenter did
start to really lose his touch after a
sort of point you know and I think it
would have been more
exciting because the thing is it's still
like when you have the prequel that they
made um which I know you've been doing
you did coverage on recently when you
have the prequel that they made it it
does it does not actually affect it just
elevates makes makes the the original
thing from the 80s is that much better
oh just made it stronger you know
where it's not that if John Carpenter
and them did one then it failed it I
don't think it would have negatively
affected it uh however that still makes
it that much more special that they
didn't even touch it again and they're
keep keeping that ending ambiguous sort
of be ponderous about it like you've had
some very successful videos really
breaking down what really happened at
the very end of that movie it would have
been more exciting uh I would have
obviously I think more people would have
tuned in for that but I do have to
question whether or not you know like
Martin scors sayi seems like he has not
lost his touch the older he has gotten
the killers of the flower Moon I was
going through Rotten Tomatoes phenomenal
reviews right now consistently whereas
John Carpenter really did start to lose
his touch but it would have been cool to
not gonna lie yeah it would have been
cool though that that alt Universe
sounds really cool the thing is though
put not intended he's obviously had
ideas for sequels rattling around in his
head since the 80s so I think it would
have been good I would have liked to
have seen it anyway obviously he was
involved with the game which is the the
that's considered Canon um he actually
plays the character in that but yeah I
would have loved to have seen that and
another one that um ties in with the
Exorcist is we talked about this last
week so the Exorcist
prequel they originally shot The
Exorcist dominion and it was pretty much
the same script they went in shot
everything
fully finished the film and then
realized uh we don't actually like it
that much so they then went back reshot
everything from scratch and called it
Exorcist the prequel or something
something stupid it's such a weird story
um they then released that people didn't
like it so they then released the
original thing they shot which people
also didn't like
surprisingly dude um can I throw mine in
there the one that I immedi the second
you brought up this topic there was one
that just sprung to mind right away I
just sent you a photo of it so like
still holding out hope Paul the Dark
Universe I think the Dark Universe is
one of the most fascinating times in
cinema that we have ever lived through
it I am still so fascinated by it
because they it was so much premature
thinking with that movie if you guys
don't remember what it is so in is 2017
if I'm not mistaken and they decide
they're going to launch the Dark
Universe which would be like the classic
Monster films being brought to life with
modern day things like Dracula
Frankenstein The Mummy launching it with
the mummy with Tom Cruz and the mummy uh
so they wanted to do all these films and
they had this big cast photo that they
put together show we already got the
talent for it Johnny Deb Javier bardam
as Frankenstein's monster Russell Crow
is jackqueline Hyde angelin and Joe Lee
as Bride of
Frankenstein um I think they wanted to
carry over Luke evans's Drive I could be
wrong about that but I think they might
have wanted to carry over uh Luke Evans
regardless even if you take Luke Evans
out you have all those other people
right these big celebrities that they
are putting front and center and then
even when you watch the Mumy
they had the dark they had a
whole cheap ass logo for it and
everything Dark Universe is launch for
it and it it was it was at least DC they
keep trying you know they keep they
launch a universe and they keep trying
to keep it going whereas Dark Universe
died right away it even ends with
because the trailers are sh showing that
like Tom Cruz versus The Mummy they
didn't tell you that he was going to
become the mummy which was hilarious and
so much went wrong with with that one
movie it's not a good
movie uh I I laugh at it but I I'm not
gonna lie I had fun when I watched it
but I can gladly acknowledge it is not a
good movie and I've never walked out of
a movie in my life before never
understood people who do it at first 10
minutes in I literally looked at my wife
and was like I feel I'm going to walk
out I feel like I'm going to walk out
and she went no just stay just stay and
I could up until that point I could
never understand why people walked out
of movies and I was watching it thinking
I'm going to walk out going to walk out
and I've seen some in my life Greg
I've seen some bloody in my life it
it treats its audience like it's stupid
it it constantly is like I only saw it
once but I just remember how they just
kept repeating itself like you got to
tell the audience what we're doing you
got to tell the audience what we're
doing and then their setup for their
Universe was so hamfist it was it just
felt we talk about like committee made
and corporate made and and this was just
all over the screen with it and then you
could also feel like probably The Clash
of Studio ever and Tom Cruz producer
mentality uh kicking in as like it's
just not a good blend of a film and then
it just completely killed this Dark
Universe and Dark Universe in a lot of
ways you know the classic Monster films
were the first Cinematic Universe uh to
Grace the Silver Screen you know the
Crossovers with Dracula and
Frankenstein's monster and Wolfman way
back in the black and white days man
that was it was like the first time we
ever had cinematic un Universe
crossovers if I'm not mistaken so this
should have been a slam dunk but they
wanted to turn it into some like weird
superhero franchise instead of
embracing that this should be a monster
verse this should be not the monster you
know what I it should be a monster like
monster movie Cinematic Universe but
they were going for some like
action horror adjacent thingy uh it was
it's it was really I mean I'm I'm I'm
glad it died it gave it allowed us to
get invisible man which is great because
Invisible Man is an awesome movie uh the
Lee one L film the same thing like how
you brought up with like uh Deadpool you
know that is one of the worst decisions
I think in in history too what they did
with the with Ryan Reynolds sewing his
mouth shut and but it allowed us to get
the Deadpool franchise and the Deadpool
franchise often riffs off of that
terrible decision that happened so
sometimes there's a blessing in disguise
for some of these choices lots of people
said the Dark Universe on Twitter as
well so shout out to Numa for saying
that one um AE for saying it Ben Friel
and Cameron who's at at Tru CP so thanks
guys for writing that in seems like lots
of people agree with the Dark Universe
because yeah just a weird move out I
thought you know what I'm going to say
something in his favor I quite liked
Russell Crowe as Dr Jackal and Mr Hyde
he was obviously getting set up to be
the Nick Fury of the entire thing but
obviously yeah if you go with like I
watched the mon I watched The Wolf Man
last week and they were having a 4K
steelbook sale on it so I thought I'll
pick that up got it watched it classic
started looking at all the other Wolfman
movies like Wolf Man vers Frankenstein
and stuff I thought let's go baby I'm
about a star I'm sick of all these other
shed universes this is my new hobby for
the next two years um and yeah it it's
insane that they try and make it like a
superhero movie and I think it's the
perfect example of putting the C before
the horse where David goer actually
recently talked about Warner Brothers um
who I'm sure will come up in this
discussion but he said um when they were
making Man of Steel and Batman v
Superman and stuff that they got called
into the office and they're like we've
planned out the next 20 years of films
and it's like mate you've you've just
had like you've got one just make one
first and yeah see how that does yeah
all the the stuff they did announcing
the stars and people that were going to
be a part of it it just it was insane
it's just such a bad move by them and
this was at a time when every single
Studio was announcing their big shared
Universe thing and I think Marvel's the
only one who actually really pulled it
off obviously the monster vers has done
pretty well F financially yeah but
critically I'm not sure those films are
that beloved but yeah what's your next
point I gotta give credit to The
Conjuring universe
they get a lot of shade The Conjuring
Universe they do but they have some
pretty good ones in there you know
Conjuring films themselves um I think a
couple of those anabal movies are pretty
damn good um I've heard the nun two is
at least an improvement over the first
nun movie I haven't seen the nun two so
I I think that the conjuring universe is
is one that surprisingly and they they
all they've all done well if I'm not
mistaken and I think that's one that we
often forget is like that is actually a
atic universe that is technically
thriving and yeah they pulled it off man
they really pulled it off but the the
other one that came to mind for because
a lot of these are just like personal
picks lot of them are more like is yeah
we could look at ones that are obvious
Financial losses for things that for
stuff they shouldn't have done or
casting choices and whatnot I'm I was
thinking of ones that just sort of
sprang to mind that sort of just clicked
with me um and I think the movie solo a
lot comes back back to me for that
because of this being one of the dumb
decisions because you know Phil Lord and
Chris Miller were ATT were directing
that movie they got fired from it and
you really feel like they probably
couldn't gotten something special from
it and that's like the big story that a
lot of people focus on and I I I started
remembering when we were thinking about
this topic was that it also failed at
the box office and I was trying to
remember like what happened then and and
and I came to me that oh yeah they
released it just like a few short months
after the Last Jedi with almost like
like very very little promotion too so
it cost like them a ton like firing
lordon Miller robbed it what of whatever
could have made it feel special and
unique right I I just automatically
believe that whatever the version they
had is better I I don't even care for I
could be 100% wrong I'll never know my
mind just tells me it's Phil Lord and
Chris Miller they tend to do something
unique and weird and it tends to connect
with audiences so I'm G to just believe
that they didn't understand that what
they were doing would have been
something special because they also
respect they also clearly respect um
fandom they also clearly respect uh
Legacy and lineage and whatnot they know
what is special about the properties
they work on for audiences they let that
shine but they also understand bringing
something unique and
special so firing them first big mistake
and then all the re-shoot that they had
to do cost them a ton of money and
then they decide to just release it with
very little promotion afterwards and
then it just tanks at the box office
when we didn't have time to it's like
you again it was an even it's under
Disney and it seemed like they were
trying to just we need to do the Marvel
thing and just try to get like two to
three movies out a year just like get
that going when before there was you
know was like force awakens one year
next year Rogue one next year Last Jedi
and then just a a few months later they
released solo a Star Wars
story and it tanked at the box office so
I think the entire handling of that just
went to and it does diminish a
little quite a bit of the anticipation
for whatever this Lando project is I
think there's a lot of Star Wars here
that you could probably dis because when
you're thinking about Star Wars
obviously the first order of business
they should have done haha no pun
intended the first order of business
they should have done was really get a
plan and order for their new Trilogy for
bringing stuff back it it is
still it still ripples through the
Cinematic Universe even when watching
Ahsoka that you can hear it within the
phandom of are they just I hope they're
not just trying to make it make sense of
how the first order came to rise and how
Palpatine returned I hope we're not
dealing with that I hope we can just
ignore that and get a new plot that
could still feel consequential and not
just about tying into whatever that mess
was because it was a mess it was a mess
I'm not even speaking to like if you
loved Last Jedi or not you know
obviously that's a fight that wages on
till the end of
time I think think that if they just had
some type of Direction because it's like
Last Jedi Ryan Johnson has talked about
like yeah I didn't really they didn't
tell me what so I just made it what I
wanted to be and then rise of Skywalker
was the the biggest reactionary piece of
content you can imagine they really
watch that I can see why people would
like Last Jedi and in the cinema right I
hated it hated it up until the point
where they do the holdo maneuver and
then then I feel it kicks off a bit and
it you know there's some good action
scenes and stuff and some nice Surprises
with the Luke I know everyone kind of
gets yeah everyone gets annoyed at that
the first time watching it I was like
they got me that was that was an all
right thing second watch I was like
that's not that good um but yeah at
least it had like story and rules and
stuff whereas I feel the rise of
Skywalker and the one genuinely one of
the the worst things I ever think that a
studio has done is how Palpatine
returned just no
explanation no setup to it completely
out the blue absolutely you can watch
the force awakens in The Last Jedi and
there's nothing in that that sets of
Palpatine back they announced it on
fortnite had that hologram out and just
somehow Palpatine returned just sums up
the entire film where it's like we don't
know how we're going to explain this
mate just throw a line in a about it
somehow he returned how what do you mean
somehow cloning um f survived the Death
Star some somehow mate don't worry about
it he's back they don't even strike a
mood with it that line they don't even
they don't even attempt to like have
some type of
ominous
mystery behind it it's so throwaway when
he says it somehow Palpatine returned
you know it's not like a punch slow Zoom
in and like somehow Palpatine returned
you know there's no Aura to it like the
characters don't really discover it
themselves kylo discovers it and for po
to be the one who delivers it I mean if
it was Leia or Luke had been alive or
something or even Luke as a force ghost
had have said it i' be like okay like
Luke had been like oh I've I've died but
I dived into the force and I tried to
look for Palpatine's Echo amongst the
cosmos but I couldn't find it that means
he's still alive
and I found part of you Ray his Essences
and you you are a Palpatine that that's
better than somehow Palpatine in and
every time like they spend a like when
they were spending ages bringing drawn
back into a sua all the time like on
slack me and the editors we were just
joking about how they could just explain
it away by just saying somehow pal
returned but I think Lucas film in
general have had so many blunders
obviously they've hired so many Direct
is DND Josh
Tran
um who Patty
Jenkins Tao's movie might get made but I
wouldn't bet the house on it there's
been so many things and even just doing
the Ryan Johnson Trilogy as well and
even just spending $300 million on
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
they just seem to be the love burning
money over at Lucas Filman wish I could
get a job over there be like what ideas
you got Paul oh Willow that's another
example made it the Disney Plus show
Willow and then scrapped it six months
later and yeah lots of things going on
there I still think though they've got
some they have made some good stuff um
and yeah they they've done some good
things so the Goodwill from me at least
is still there but sometimes when they
announce stuff I just think what the
hell are you doing now another Studio
that causes a lot of issues and this get
Warner Brothers I mean they got brought
up so much and just their handling of
the CE EU oh my God from the off it was
pretty much trying to catch it with
Marvel they wanted they wanted their MCU
and they didn't care how quickly they
got there how botched it was just set
these Heroes up and they obviously
forced half an hour to be cut out of
Batman v Superman and then Suicide Squad
was completely taken out of David A's
hands and cut by a trailer company
completely messed up the tone of what he
was was originally going for basically
turned it into a music video took his
Soulful um introspective superhero movie
and try to turn it into Deadpool and
Guardians of the Galaxy and from then I
don't think they've ever fully recovered
obviously Justice League I mean you
could spend three hours on a podcast
talking about all the mishaps with that
the CGI
mustache I don't they're releasing that
is insane in that state
and just since then they've never really
managed to recuperate you know they've
the way they've gone on with the SNY
fans and like what we think you guys are
all scumbags but here's your movie but
by the way there's not going to be
anything more after this and it's just
in insane and they've had so many false
starts and management changing in behind
the scenes and directions bringing Henry
Cav back for the end of Black Adam
telling the rock there's going to be a
big black Adam verse and then the next
being like Oh no sorry mate you're out
completely uh and even now he can still
kind of feel the footprints of it and I
actually saw this week that Blue Beetle
is the lowest grossing DC EU film of all
time and we've just had this constant
downward spiral and I think they
completely killed all the the Goodwill
with the fans there um I know I
constantly bang on about the DCU and
people get fed up of me I mean if you're
playing a drinking game and you've been
listening this podcast and me slagging
off the DCU you're probably dead right
now uh but yeah lots of weird things
that Warner Brothers have done in
general with that property and to think
that they've got all their characters
and they're still fumbling the ball 10
years later after doing Man of Steel
it's crazy it's crazy yeah I mean we we
this topic is often looking at past
decisions in movies whereas with DC it's
kind of like an
ongoing like there's so there's been so
much negativity that has happened from
just James gun an like that's very
recent news of James gun um prematurely
announcing all these changes before they
had a chance for all this stuff to be
release Warner Brothers had other movies
too were just yes so I was just about to
say that so um Michael J at let's talk
Mets he said WB putting all their 2021
movie releases on HBO Max same day as
the as cost them Nolan uh who would
obviously go on to make close to a
billion dollars with Oppenheimer at the
moment um and yeah just the amount of
money they lost by doing that absolutely
insane just crazy decision to drop it I
mean I'm not me but I knew someone who
wasn't even going to the theater and
they were just getting 4K versions of
movies that had just come out that day
and watching them H and yeah what an
insane thing to do just asking to give
away money and lose all that obviously I
get you know it was during the pandemic
and people didn't exactly know what
movie theaters were going to be like and
how to even handle releasing content in
a in a time like that but wow there was
also a desate attempt it was a desperate
attempt for streaming War success man it
was the it was embarrassing with good
for us it helped us for Content like on
our end as a YouTuber amazing uh but it
did CH I think that more than anything
else negatively affected the feelings of
audien's desire to truly go to the the
theaters you know being much more
selective imagine all those
movies see the thing at least with
Disney
plus they were like you'll still have to
pay to watch watch Mulan you'll still
have to pay to watch Black Widow you
know uh the
pvod but when you just drop it on a
streaming
service it robs it of feeling like a a
cinematic experience it does uh
something that where you have to go to
the theaters to witness this you know
and while some movies like Dune did
still do pretty well Godzilla versus
Kong still did do pretty well in the
actual theaters you know uh a lot of
those movies ended up being considered
flops due to it being released on
streaming uh on HBO Max and I think that
programed that conditioned people in a
certain way and I still think that that
effect is is really felt like while
we've had some massive successes this
year things like Super Mario Brothers
things like Barbie
Oppenheimer the the fight to get people
consistently going to the theaters that
that the the thing is about
consistency it makes sense to me why we
also get some some of the biggest flops
we've we've like this year has been like
terrible for Disney absolutely terrible
for Disney and while we're talking about
this is Warner brother's decision dis
Disney being in compliance with like
Universal I I think the only thing they
really dropped was if I'm not mistaken
the thing they dropped was just trolls
World Tour but everything else they did
reserve for the cinema and and I and it
it's shocking to think like it's still a
couple years and it you could still see
the ripple effect of it all yeah I mean
they completely changed viewing habits
and killed off such a massive amount of
money for themselves by doing this and
affecting people's behavior to where
they now just wait for streaming for a
lot of titles and in the same way people
don't really buy physical media anymore
that that's all because of streaming and
how much they've lent into this thing
that's constantly losing their money
it's like bro what a dumb decision um
now I'm just looking on rollingstone.com
they've got some they've actually got a
list of the 50 worst decisions in movie
history um some funny ones here ja ja
Binks and just talking about how you
know George Lucas came back with Star
Wars and uh launched it with Jinks and
it wasn't wasn't well loved at the time
they also talk about Gus Van Sans
creating a shot for shot remake of
psycho which if youve ever have you ever
watched that shot for shot remake of
psycho the 90s remake of it it's Absolut
it is it's mental to watch because it is
it's the exact same film like everything
is exactly the same but it's in color
with different actors and you just think
why why have you made this movie the the
original is still there there's there's
slight differences like tiny bits of
nudity that you actually see and okay
they enhance a tiny bit of sexual stuff
I'll
say that's I want to point I want to be
that guy Paul I want to be that guy okay
I want to be the guy get so pedantic
about it and just I'm like well
technically they changed this so they
did change it a tiny bit no 99% of it is
shot for shot number five on this list
Matt Damon turning down Avatar including
10% of the back end um so obviously I
mean throughout history we know lots of
actors have turned down big roles for
example I think sha conry turned down
Lord of the Rings playing Gandalf
because he didn't quite understand it
yeah yeah Will Smith um obviously turned
down Neo from The Matrix he he has G on
to say that K Reeves was perfect I mean
Keo Reeves was born for that role yeah
you can't imagine anyone else as Neo and
yeah but he he would he would have made
a lot of money off that um and obviously
his wife starred in the second and third
one and fourth one as well as well H but
yeah in 2000s Matt Damon had the
opportunity when H James Cameron
approached him about playing the lead
role in Avatar he was offered 10% on the
back end as an enticement the only
problem was it conflicted with his work
on the Bourn movie so Damon basically
said you know he didn't want to leave
that movie early and leave them in the
Lurch um so he didn't do it and the
decision cost him $250 million
throughout the years Damon has talked
about this several times but Cameron
feels he needs to let it go Cameron said
he's yeah he's beating himself up over
this I really think you know Matt you're
kind of like one of the biggest movie
stars in the world doesn't matter
there's always more there's always more
get over it if there's more hat it the
number four is oh go on I I I don't know
if it's on the Rolling Stone list um
wait what's number four is this because
there's one slap Will Smith yes that is
one of the worst decisions in Hollywood
history is that really on here I don't
know if that's like a Hollywood decision
I think the the stupid decision was the
security being like ah he's probably
just going up there for a joke it's
probably just going to be funny um well
no but you wouldn't expect it like I
remember I went to bed and I woke up and
there were tweets about it saying I
watched it live man I didn't I didn't
think it was real
was I think it was Ryan Ary actually
predicted it judging by his timeline so
he said oh like one of the Tweet was oh
God he's gonna go up there and then the
next tweet was like no freaking way so
he predicted that he was going to go up
there but I woke up the next day and I
seen just I I genuinely couldn't believe
it was one of those things I was reading
it thinking ah they're having a laugh
like they're making a joke about how
boring the Oscars were was cuz all the
tweets were like oh this is so boring
someone needs to slap like you know what
I mean someone oh Will Smith slap Chris
Rock and I'm like yeah whatever and then
yeah for to actually see it yeah um
obviously he still won the award that
night he got applauded and stuff but
it's something that's gonna hang over
his head for all the way until the end
of his career and even now I feel like
he like I don't give a if he
slapped him like I really don't care I
you I'll watch a Will Smith movie
tomorrow like I get obviously not the
way you could act but I mean the guys
apologize we've all well we haven't all
been at the Oscars but you know we've
lost our cool over stuff and done
something stupid it just happened to be
in front of millions of people worldwide
at a prestigious event that he's been
working towards for his entire life but
I like I don't give a about it but
probably get hate for saying that but um
obviously don't hit people yeah guys out
there don't rush on stage and hit
standup comedians
but yeah having that at number four when
the John Landis thing is actually I
think it's number seven on the list um
in case you don't know joh we talked
about it earlier but yeah that's crazy
how I think that's probably worse in the
world so much worse that is so much
worse number three is Blockbuster gets
an offer to buy Netflix for $50 million
in 2000 and turns it down yeah
completely it out um number two Bert
Reynolds turns down James Bond The
Godfather Star Wars Pretty Woman and one
flu over the cookoo's nest that's like
an insane amount imagine if you had that
in your filmography all those films and
number one is racist movie The Conqueror
gives its cast cancer and probably kills
John Wayne yeah that's insane the the
one that the one of the ones there's two
that come to mind for me um right away
that I want to make sure to touch on
um the first one I don't know I actually
don't know how you feel about this one I
feel like one you'll probably be on the
same page as me and there's the other
one where I'm not sure how you'll feel
uh I'll go with the one where I'm not
sure how you feel uh the fact that they
didn't do the alien sequel with Neil
Blom Camp who I think would have been a
perfect fit for it uh with Sigourney
Weaver and bringing back uh Michael Bean
as well to do that proper alien sequel
and I feel like that would have been
much more
enticing
interesting
than alien Covenant which killed that
prequel franchise of the Prometheus
universe or whatever they were doing uh
that that to me is a really big
disappointment and so it's not really
like the one of the worst decisions in
Hollywood I'd say uh I I feel like
actually the decisions that they made
for Alien 3 I would probably put up
there as some of the worst decisions
they've done in
Hollywood the other one is more of like
a wish that I think would have panned
out better is they I mean they turned
The Hobbit this this really tight book
into a
Trilogy and originally they wanted they
wanted gal delor to do it and gal delor
was on board to do it and I don't
remember all the reasons why g l Toro
couldn't do it I'm sure there was
I'm sorry it couldn't be bothered
probably like three three hour movies s
that I'm off he wanted to just to make
it a a two-parter um two movies and I
think I think gal Toro would have
brought something different instead of
feeling like another Lord of the Rings
but a discount version you know and I
know there was a lot working against
Peter Jackson on that one it seemed like
it really destroyed him to have like
your greatest Trilogy your biggest
passion project ever and then to do The
Hobbit trilogy like everything about the
way the Hobbit went down just sounds
like a nightmare you even have that
footage that went out of Ian McKellen
like breaking down on set about how the
acting experience was going uh so the
entire development of The Hobbit movies
I think was some of the some just
terrible decision-making just just the
the concept of turning into a Trilogy
was just not a smart call to me and I
think Galo Toro's version would have
helped distinguish it from I think it
would have been to make it feel in the
same universe as the Lord of the Rings
one but still distinguish it and give
you something different and have more of
that Fantastical wonder that deloro can
bring uh to his to his like to his films
and I think if The Hobbit movies went
down better that's that would have
helped Aid in the interest and possibly
the way the development went down of
rings of power as well if they even if
if rings of power would still be the
thing that they would decide to do
ultimately ly because it's like you do
the trilogy and the trilog is great of
of Lord of the Rings and then they they
follow it up with The Hobbit films which
does damage like Goodwill with your
audience for the Lord of the Rings
universe that you are building
out yeah I I actually quite like well I
don't want to say like like's a strong
word I am entertained by The Hobbit
trilogy obviously I know it's not as
good and but whenever I'm starting a lot
of the Rings watch through I'll just
build up to it put it on in the
background you know let it play out it
has some funny moments some good
characters in it but yeah they did drag
it out it shouldn't have been like three
three hour movies or whatever it was um
yeah that's that's and obviously you
could argue that Amazon paying a billion
to make that Lord of the Rings TV show
was a crazy crazy crazy crazy um inan
saying um but yeah that have you got any
more there an interesting one I read
that was uh talking about this comes
directly from homeboy well this will be
the last one um and then we'll turn it
over to you guys to talk about it so
John cool
goofball uh so he was saying that during
the Disney takeover with Fox buying all
the stuff um they basically shot Mr
Sinister footage shelled it had tons of
X Force scripts ready to go shelled it
and yeah apparently there was lots of
X-Men projects that we would have had
but Disney took over and shelled it now
I don't think that's up there with like
some of the most controversial things
we've skirted around on this but yeah we
we we're obviously open here you guys
I'm sure you've got loads of things
going through your head right now
thinking oh what was that they should
never have done that they should never
have made the I'm trying to think of a
good one the you know what they should
have done
they they shouldn't have
done another Phoenix attempt in the
X-Men Universe with making it Simon same
guy directorial debut the same guy who
wrote X-Men the Last St that is yeah
that is not a smart call I mean he's
done a lot of great work in the X-Men
universe but we're like we we definitely
know that there's maybe you shouldn't
have him do this one as a
direct
how did you mess it up again like how do
you get given the same thing and you
still get it wrong redemp it's like
that's that is redemption moment man
this is where you redeem yourself and
yeah that was not that was a that was a
slog so yeah just uh let us know your
thoughts because I'm sure you sure you
got lots of stuff going around your head
right now that we've we missed out don't
just write stuff like Harvey Weinstein
obviously it's bad Harvey Weinstein
worst decision ision Hollywood yeah to
obviously top stupid stuff like what
we've just said there like dark Phoenix
films but keep it lighthearted guys
we're trying to make a fun podcast here
and leave your thoughts on what you
think some dumb decisions in Hollywood
are would love to hear from you I'm sure
you're going to be typing away right now
saying we're haters and shills H but
pause that for a second and just write
what a dumb decision is and yeah thanks
as always for checking us out if you
want to buy some merch it's just below
the video you want to support us on
Spotify go over there cross the spoil
Amazon music hopefully next week my
voice is back to normal or write if
write in the comments if you want me to
keep getting viruses and I'll do it for
you guys but yeah thanks uh thanks for
sitting with us and we'll see you next
time thank you again Greg for joining me
of
course